my name is dawn delhi i'm a senior
scientist with dari indeed based in
canterbury but for the last 10 or so
years have been involved in research
projects around wintering in also fog
system design and Zetland
in South Otago and currently I'm leading
the farm systems implementation at
southern Derry hub and a couple of
projects relating to what a bit of
feeding so today and my session what I'm
going to try to do is bring together
some of the key messages that you've
heard from Nick and Helen and relation
to good management practice and animal
welfare and talk about the importance of
pedak setup and contingency plans for
adverse weather and partway through I'm
going to flick over to Olivia and she's
going to give us some perspective from a
max livestock point of view so next
slide please
so why is it important that we have
pedak grazing plans well first of all it
helps to see wintering expectations and
if you can do this with your team it
means that everybody is on the same page
and they know what success is going to
look like for your farm it also helps
the team to understand the way that you
do things in a particular way on your
farm so we know there's lots of
different systems out here and everybody
does things slightly differently so
understanding the why for your farm
means that they'll be in a better
position to make informed decisions if
things are going off plan also by having
individual paddock grazing plans you can
identify and highlight the risks of
specific paddocks so if I think about
the southern dairy hub we went to on
both our upper terrace and also on our
lower flex we know that the soil type on
our lowest terrace for a lot of the flat
as Hibiya we have a number of paddocks
with critical source areas and also we
have a waterway that runs through the
middle so those paddocks have quite
different risks in terms of
implementation of grazing compared with
the ones on our upper terrace the other
thing was having these pallet grazing
plans is it allows you to discuss
implant for the adverse weather events
and think about some of those things
that Helens just highlighted in relation
to animal welfare and it yes the the
overall objective is really looking at
maximizing the chances of achieving your
spring curving in lemon targets so what
I'm going to go through an exercise
thank so much
as just the key factors to consider in
the plane and it's really about bringing
together things that neck in hello
talked about onto into a concise form
and sharing it with the team or
developing with the team so what I'm
going to talk about is and they recently
released
brickbeard wintering resource it's an
update obvious accessible imposture
wintering material that's been out there
previously so in terms of the plan
thinking about your critical source
areas in waterways putting them on your
on your map then with it you can look at
your grazing direction and how you can
utilize in a shelter where your bales
are going to be placed how you're going
to manage your portable troughs and
alongside the back fencing and then also
looking at more access points you've got
to the paddock and do your specific
access points for people animals and
vehicles so we'll just move on and look
at what the resources are that you need
to develop this plan so it's not
actually a lot of resource required
either affirm map or within the brake
feed wintering guides there are some
resource templates that you can use if
you don't have a farm that you need some
writing material pens or pencils the
farm team in some dedicated time so what
you may choose to do is if you've got a
number of panics on your farm and you've
got a few on your team maybe give each
member of the team
I've had it to go away and think through
the initial plan for and then come back
as a group exercise or n discuss what
everybody's come up with one of the
things that we've found valuable at the
southern dairy hub is using Google Maps
over our farm map and from there we can
pick up sometimes some more subtle
critical source areas that we might need
to deal with they might not be weak when
they're in grass but potentially can be
a challenge
when the Herren crop so yeah just get
your farm team involved and start
documenting how you're planning on
grazing those paddocks next slide thanks
Hamish the other thing with developing
those pellet plans is thinking about
your how that fits with your address
with a contingency plan so Helens
highlighted some of these aspects were
really so from the animal welfare
perspective the plan needs to consider
access to shelter so we have you've got
those opportunities what does the you're
lying surface look like and also the
access to feed so in potentially having
additional feed available for periods of
adverse events from an environmental
perspective we need to take into
consideration and you salt right and
what that looks like after 2 or 3 days
of heavy rain in wet weather looking at
any areas that maybe came come larger
risk in terms of runoff and to surface
water ways and and particularly any
flooding risk that there might be as
well in the third area for our
contingency plan to consider is around
people in safety so having developed the
plan as everybody on board with it and
how easy is it to implement when they be
it may arise how can you keep your
people safe and being able to access the
the paddocks in the animals through that
period of time and for snow means
keeping particularly animals safe if we
lose power during that event so just
move on and look at some of the factors
or things that you can consider in terms
of an invis plan for cash walk so things
Hamish
so in terms our contingency plan for
cattle some of the options well
initially we need to think about and
their feed budgeting process having an
additional feed on hand for that period
of time so recommendations having an
extra team sit there looking at options
to increase the area are available
through this adverse event so that might
be by giving an extra break up of crop
we need to be mindful with Fatih Beach
and depending on what the allocation
level is that that may not be feasible
option without risking animal health
issues however there may be instances we
actually taking your back fence further
away from the crop face may allow the
animals to EXCI some drier areas that
I've already been through and gives them
more space to spread out and find those
those better areas when you're
developing your pet grazing plan looking
it is their opportunity to save crop and
a drier lower risk part of the paddock
may be a week's worth of feed Thea that
you can bring animals back to if
necessary or as I mentioned earlier what
we look at the southern dairy hunters
the opportunity to bring animals of a
heavier soils on to dry a lower risk
Penix up on the upper terrace if you're
looking at out of pedak options there
might be opportunity to stand off and
laneways or yards or some rough grass
areas but it's important to remember
that cows don't particularly or animals
don't particularly like lying on hard
concrete surfaces so that's really a
short-term solution and there are some
may be opportunity to use some safety
blocks when I say save tree blocks
probably not a good idea to have your
pregnant animals and areas with
macrocarpa but there might be some pine
plantations you can use so now I'm going
to hand over to Olivia who's going to go
through and what you might need to
consider differently from the sheep
perspective
thanks for that dawn use some of those
cater options obviously guys can be used
but for other livestock
including sheep and deer there might be
some other options that you haven't
thought of and I'm just going to go
through some of them for you to consider
so getting livestock to shout in areas
with water you may be able to consider a
grass runoff paddock when the weather is
foul and have other options like
utilizing green and sheet nuts while in
those areas if it's going to be for
extended period of time to make sure you
can maximize shelter again you can use
those lower risk Drive headaches as well
you may consider larger breaks or day
breaks or no number of people are doing
that now as well from a deer perspective
do you require bigger breaks than cattle
and some deer farmers have been giving
deer the whole paddock rather than strip
grazing ensuring that critical source
area is well protected the BET fencing
of deer can increase stress which can
result in spacing so it's best to
properly avoid that if possible but each
situation again is going to be different
you look at prioritizing your stock
classes so body condition scoring at
skinning could be an option and look at
transferring liner animals to grass and
supplement you could be looking at doing
some of us now as well if Fleming dates
are split ensure that you feed stock
based on their lemming and carving dates
and if you want to share and I'm sure I
don't need to tell you but the shearing
increases feed demand and freshly shorn
sheep are at higher risk in bad weather
so make sure that you're considering the
use of cover combs to reduce that risk
lifters may be needed as well depending
on their season and reduce that risk by
just sharing one full sheet at a time
and having a three-day get between
especially if their weather is really
unpredictable so that pretty much covers
it the adorne so proceed back to you
thanks for that Olivia so just a few of
the factors to consider in terms of your
abuse with a plan does all the team know
when and how to implement that plan it's
really important if you're the maybe the
key decision-maker and you're going to
be on farm for a period of time so
having some clear triggers is to win
that plan as needed is really important
need to consider the crop type that the
animals are grazing as well and can you
keep feeding it during the adverse
weather event this is particularly
important for for the beach where we
know it's really important that animals
are transitioned onto on to the crop and
have a consistent diet so if you're
pulling them off and are for more than a
couple of days then you might you would
need to have some re transitioning
picked it into your plan or an
alternative might be to hit some lifted
for the beach that you can give them a
net out of paddock area so they stay on
that drive through that period thinking
about the impact of a decreased feed
utilization during those adverse events
on and take and how you're going to
manage making sure that your animals are
getting enough feed through that period
of time and as I've mentioned previously
thinking about your access in and out of
paddocks
for stock in people if you do have to
move your stroke out and maybe that the
gateways not not looking the beasts are
the options to drop fences and move them
out over a bigger area we acknowledge
that it's pretty difficult to completely
mitigate the conditions but by having a
plan you can definitely look at options
to minimize the impact so just in terms
of finishing up by hemming sitting down
taking some time and developing these
plans it's a really great opportunity to
see clear expectations around what
success looks like for wintering on your
property by involving the team and the
process they can understand the why
behind the activities and tasks that
they're going out in doing on a daily
basis and why it might be different
between parrots on the property it
encouraged you to steel with pride and
any ideas from your farming colleagues
is Helen mentioned people do have lots
of
really good ideas and they're doing
things differently so just look just
talk to your neighbors and and others
and find out what are doing especially
in terms of the adverse weather and I
guess really encourage that doing
something is better than doing nothing
and real value in their pain and
everybody being on the same page at the
start of winter so I just want to finish
off by with a quote from Napoleon that's
his plan your work and work your plan